When my dad goes to work he does really important
stuff he stops bad guys and keeps everyone safe
when people are in trouble he saves the day
he's always smiling when he does it my dad's job
saving the world
My dad will survive fought International
today's Heroes tomorrow's future
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my boys season four teaser trailer video
obviously I had a funny little clip there or Ryan
talking about home later because he's living at
Vaught Tower full time now so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos they're
working on season four right now they confirmed
that Jeffrey Dean Morgan is going to be playing a
new character so they're just slowly accumulating
more and more Supernatural cameos well and and
they're questions that I think that uh we're
asking now in in uh in real life uh I think
the boys in particular it is a really great
job of kind of paralleling what's going on uh
in the world this episode uh you know they talk
about uh everyone having cameras and how that has
changed everything that's it's amazingly topical
um I think Kripke has just done an amazing job
now all they have to do is get Jared Padalecki
to Cameo during season five you can let me
know in the comments who you would want him
to Cameo as most of the characters that they're
introducing on the show in successive seasons
are still people from the comics but but there
aren't that many Comics so some of the characters
they just create on the fly but the reason why
they're releasing Ryan teasers like this with
homelander with him seemingly in this weird
situation at Vaught trying to promote their
narrative is because season 4 is primarily about
the Battle for Ryan's Soul that's kind of what
they teased at the end of season three the whole
idea that Ryan was slowly kind of drinking the
Kool-Aid getting this negative reinforcement
learning all the wrong things when homelander
introduces him to the crowd of his Fanboys they
are like Todd screaming yay I'm so happy to see
homelander kill a whole bunch of people the whole
idea this whole time is that Ryan has felt like
an outsider they've been hiding him he's been
trying to hide his powers he hates his powers
because he feels like so much of an outsider they
make him an outsider before he had his big split
with butcher he was talking to Kimiko about that
because she wanted to get rid of her powers too
for the same reason the difference with Ryan
though is that when homelander introduces him
and he sees homelander kill that dude in front of
everyone and they cheer him on for it like they
love him for it Ryan's like wait a minute people
will love me for my Powers I don't have to hide
them anymore this is wonderful but the whole idea
is that like his young brain isn't connecting all
the dots yet like wait a minute no no this is
terrible that's why they have the very ominous
music that they end on is Ryan gives this kind of
evil looking smile like oh no what's happened and
the funny thing is is that even though homelander
is a completely terrible person and you don't
want him to pollute Ryan with his ideology deep
inside homelander is kind of going through the
same battle that's going on inside Ryan as well
like he has those two halves they have that great
scene of homelander versus homelander why the long
face tiger when we were kids alone in the bedroom
I got us through we right they kind of made it
seem like he was full-blown schizophrenic like
he had multiple personalities inside him that
were battling for Supremacy there's the young
boy inside him they were actually some flashbacks
they included in earlier Seasons too that I'll
talk about because they're actually really cool
deleted scenes they show you homelander as a
kid kind of going through the same thing that Ryan
went through but getting even worse lessons in how
it twisted him and he turned into the person that
you see today the monster that you see today but
the whole idea is that this version of homelander
this personality just wants people to love him
he'll do anything it takes to get people to love
him no matter what he doesn't care about killing
people he doesn't even care about being home later
he just cares about being part of the crowd so to
speak like just being part of a family that was
why he had that weird mommy Kink with Madeline
Stillwell because he didn't really have a mother
like he had a mother biologically carried him to
term but essentially he was created in a lab so
he didn't really have a mother and his mother
died during childbirth so a lot of this is on Stan
Edgar like Stan Edgar was primarily responsible
for his creation and what eventually happened to
the way that they raised him that's why he keeps
referring to the bad room like they put him in
the quote-unquote bad room that would nullify his
powers or that would at least contain him somewhat
technically the idea is that there is nothing on
planet Earth that can contain homelander like
that's how powerful he's meant to be that's why
Ryan is such a big deal because he's like one
of the first people that we know of that was
born of someone with compound B Powers because
technically it's supposed to make you sterile
that's why it's such a big deal that he was born
like wait a minute it's actually possible in the
idea that somehow Ryan is much more powerful
also because he was born naturally he doesn't
have compound V flowing through his veins the same
way that homelander and all the other compound via
supers do so theoretically they couldn't nullify
his powers the same way but then you have the Evil
Personality inside him that's talking to him like
how did I get us through all those times in the
bad room it sounds like what happened when he
was young he developed a split personality to
deal with all the trauma that he was experiencing
and that became like the really hardcore Evil
Personality and that'll be the one that Ryan
winds up having to actually do battle with I
think the whole idea is they want to tease during
season three is like there were a couple people
like butcher Huey and Soldier Boy almost took
homelander down like they got him down pinned for
a little while but he still got away so even with
everything that they threw at him they were barely
barely able to get the drop on him so ultimately
the only person that will be able to actually take
him down would be someone like Ryan so they're
kind of turning this into Like a Star Wars Darth
Vader Luke Skywalker scenario where in Star Wars
obviously Return of the Jedi Luke Skywalker tries
to redeem Darth Vader successfully but I think
because they don't want to be too on the nose
with it and because this will go a couple more
seasons probably whatever their version of that
winds up being there'll be a big twist on it like
he probably will not be able to redeem homelander
ultimately but you tell all these jokes and we
talk about Ryan being the only person who can
defeat home later what if the only person who can
defeat homelander is homelander like it literally
and metaphorically becomes a battle between
homelander's two personalities that would be crazy
the problem with Ryan and homelander is that Ryan
just isn't getting any of that message like the
people that are around him now primarily
homelander are all vot people they want to
turn him into the next homelander the other big
narrative that's going to be happening in season
four is the whole battle over the White House like
who's going to control the white house because
even though it seems like there are a couple
different forces on the show that are trying to
control the White House ultimately it's really
just about Vaught trying to control the White
House if you think about it this way the whole
idea is that Victoria Neuman wants to win the
vice presidency on Robert singer's ticket she was
vying for all this power making all these deals
backstabbing people betraying people she betrayed
Stan Edgar she threatened to kill Starlight if she
didn't help her tow the party line and help her
win more political power and even though it seems
like she hates homelander and hates Vaught like
everything that Vada is doing the whole idea is
that Stan Edgar's long-term plan was to control
the White House and he was grooming her to be
able to eventually do that the Hawaii is that he
was behind everything Victoria Newman was doing
the whole time and he even when she betrayed him
he seemed bemused by it like aha the student has
finally become the master she's done exactly what
I trained her to do so it still seems like even
now Victoria Newman is still doing what Stan
Edgar wanted her to do fulfilling his dream of
controlling the White House if you remember way
back in season two they sort of teased this with
Robert singer's character when he was talking to
him about literally telling the president what he
was supposed to be doing like wait a minute you
want to control the White House yes absolutely
I want to control the White House back then it
was about them starting to get compound V in the
military then by season three he'd reveal his real
long-term plan is to basically get rid of their
superhero business like basically get rid of the
Disney side of their company like the extremely
evil version of Disney that was just fronting
compound V superheroes so they can make more money
like we got this formula that can turn people into
Superheroes how can we best monetize this well
let's create some fake superheroes it'd be like if
Disney had the ability to create real superheroes
and they built the Marvel Brand around that just
as a way to make money but then you reveal during
season three that that was actually kind of a
lost cause they could make more money just by
being a core pharmaceutical company like an even
more evil version of Pfizer so ultimately he was
planning on getting rid of all their superhero
business and just selling the temporary compound
V to the military and making way more money with
way less downside way less collateral damage they
actually teased that during season one that
vought superheroes cause more damage than they
prevent the whole idea with butcher's character
obviously is still trying to win Ryan over but
because he's so terrible like he's just as bad as
homelanders in a completely different direction
currently he and Ryan are on the out so he's got
to do something to convince Ryan that he actually
cares about him and is doing things in his best
interests but Ryan just isn't ready to see that
at the moment Starlight formally joins the boys at
the end of season three so now they have another
like really powerful character and even though
I think that Victoria Newman and Robert Singer
will successfully win the presidency I don't
know if that's going to happen during season
four so I'll stretch that into season five they
might win it like right at the end of the season
and then they'll deal with them actually being
in office during season 5 the final Arc of the
boy's comic book was basically them battling it
out in the white house with this big political
play so I don't know how many seasons they're
going to drag that on but there's been a bunch
of stuff that they've added that was not in the
comic book I think they're planning on at least
five seasons but they could go to like seven
seasons that they really wanted to and they
have this boys gen V spin-off which is all about
the godolkan university in a spin-off from the
Red River Institute that they teased during season
three they've got all these compound V kids that
are coming through Red River Institute which
is basically like a place for parents to throw
away the kids or parents who wind up accidentally
killing their parents and then don't have any so
it's kind of like a glorified holding facility for
compound V kids but vot develops this University
for kids that seem like they have potential to
earn a lot of money for them like they have useful
Powers so we'll see a bunch of them during this
boys spin-off and it'll be kind of like a cross
between the boys Series in The Hunger Games with
them all battling it out for a potential place
on the seven so we'll be connected to the main
series and feed into the boys season four like
we'll see the spin-off and then we'll see season
4 or there's a whole bunch of other stuff going on
like it's going to get really crazy so if there's
anything that I didn't talk about in the video
that you have questions about during season four
just write it below in the comments big reminder
that the Last of Us episodes are starting tonight
my full episode one video will post later you can
click here for my Last of Us episode one review
and click here for my brand new Kang time travel
scene breakdown from Ant-Man the wasp quantumania
big connections to Fantastic Four and Doctor Doom
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!